[Música]
sube el agua por tuve el agua
encontrar la voz para encontrarte vos
dicen o decían en los colegios en clases
de biología el ser humano nace crece se
reproduce y muere
voy a hablar o bailar o cantar un poco
cada uno de esos momentos para observar
qué pasa con la voz en este camino en
este paso por la existencia
nací
con llanto y silencio nace en medio del
grito o el canto con voz con dolor con
miedo con luz con todo el amor de la
creación
llora y escucha en el llanto su madre le
canta con susurro que lo meses lo
enternece lo calma lo acompaña abraza su
voz en el llanto abraza su silencio
abraza su canto lo calienta lo en tibia
lo amamanta continuando la conexión más
perfecta del vientre que alimenta con
sangre al seno que alimenta con leche
silencio y latido del corazón
silencio del pensamiento y la voz del
corazón que late en la madre y en el
propio cuerpo
antoine de saint exupéry escribe en la
petición un nuevo avión clave clicker
esencial es tan visible por elección
solo se ve bien con el corazón lo
esencial es invisible a los ojos
en ese momento todos sabemos ver todos
sabemos escuchar el silencio el latido y
en el latido la voz
verdad
[Música]
y sí sí
ya yo vi
lan de colchón y
[Música]
yo
altadis richter
en forma
solo
miro baby
ver
el vídeo
[Música]
one office morning
y algo normal
[Música]
simple
vengan
los prior uy
anoche
y tu disco
y allí
money
del fin
uy tardía
mami
más
[Música]
rimba
graham
[Música]
crece
la madre y el padre acompañan la voz a
la vez que el llanto con calma sabia los
padres maestros que van al ritmo del
afán se verán callando la voz y callando
el llanto que al no poderse escuchar sea
silencia cada vez más secando a la vez
lágrimas y canciones
le dicen sentado callado
juicioso
sentado y callado y juicioso sentado
callado
sentado que haya dos juicios sentados
callado juicioso y callado juicios o
sentado fallado juicios o sentado
callado juicios o intentar callado
juicios o sentado callado juicioso
dicen los colegios formar seres libres
autónomos responsables bien resaltados y
enmarcados en cuadros de excel
autónomo viene del conocimiento del ser
que viene de escuchar
responsable de la capacidad de responder
libre de la capacidad
de expresar que viene de escuchar
donde la felicidad que promueve no
pretenden sino puedo escucharme como sé
que me hace feliz
llega a ser quién eres
dijo píndaro
pero si no escucho lo que me mueve lo
que me emociona lo que me hace llorar o
cantar lo que me guste me disgusta cómo
llego a ser quien soy
sócrates viaja caminando en exploración
al interior y dice conócete a ti mismo
pero si no escucho
si no me escucho
si no me escucho si no me escucho
se volvió tan poderoso el conócete a ti
mismo que le hicieron tomar la cicuta
la libertad parte del autoconocimiento
de la exploración permanente el andar el
encontrar el soltar y el que es capaz de
soltar suelta el miedo
suelta el miedo también que es la
herramienta para el control y la
manipulación
no le conviene una sociedad estructurada
en premios y castigos en cielos y en
infiernos que la risa borra el temor
la guardería el colegio la universidad
la empresa y tantos hogares enseñan el
orden la estructura la rutina
importantes para una disciplina del
quehacer donde entonces se enseña el
quehacer
llegamos cuadro a cuadro a una sociedad
que sigue estando regida por principios
platónicos y aristotélicos una
estructura en el crecer que va formando
una relación platónica con el cuerpo en
donde se reconocen la identidad la
seguridad del orden únicamente en el
mundo de las ideas del pensamiento y de
la razón
la razón bien separada de la cabeza
porque el cuerpo
es el lugar del pecado
aquí una pequeña nota al pie
una nota del papel en la religión como
maestra dura del alma del ánimo del
aliento para un bien funcionamiento
político estructura del poder económico
estructura de clases social estructura
de relaciones moral estructura del
espíritu
para que la estructura del espíritu no
tambalea se destina como lugar de la
rabia y la vergüenza el cuerpo y así se
niega se oculta sea calla
de esa manera llega incluso a prohibirse
la risa la risa
la risa que es la única capaz de poner
todo en su lugar pues reacomoda el miedo
en un espacio justo y omnipotente se
silencia en la tentación y el coraje la
valentía el temple el valor la bravura y
van creciendo así en tamaño cuerpos
humanos o siervos bien educados
mientras las almas y rugidos de lobos y
tigres as quedan sumidos en el olvido
eterno
nuestro querido platón propone un corte
sutil y profundo entre la cabeza y el
cuerpo que resalta el mundo de las ideas
al frente y en la frente con un mundo de
la caverna perdido en los pies y el
corazón el corte se da en el cuello pero
no se decapita sino que sedes
corporativas
queda partida la garganta que es la voz
la expresión la creación y al partir el
sonido partir el sonido se parte al ser
mismo
la garganta con arena
tu voz tiene la pena que malena no canto
[Música]
canta la gente está aplaudiendo
y aunque te estés muriendo no conocen tu
dolor
[Música]
y acá
la gente bien
habría que encontrar una canción justa
con la voz que permita un recorrido
sensato
sereno
con éxito
porque en el corte quedan sin camino la
emoción la sensación la verdad en el
presente del cuerpo y llega una voz en
tercera persona simulada ajena
desconocida a reemplazar esa de adentro
que un día lloró y se calmó en el seno
de la madre
se reproduce
nos reproducimos en hijos y en obras
en ideas en creaciones en acciones
pero le hemos puesto también collar y
cadena en garganta y órganos sensuales
a la expresión ya de la biología en los
vínculos de vida ya del alma en los
enlaces de la palabra el silencio la voz
nos hemos centrado de centrado como
sociedad al occidente y nos hemos
olvidado de ver por dónde sale el sonido
del sol el sonido de la fertilidad de la
fecundación de la cosecha
se nos ha olvidado de reproducir
reproducirnos en el sentido más íntimo y
más sagrado de la palabra se nos ha
olvidado hacer el amor parir y amamantar
alimentar criar
y con eso conversar escuchar aprender y
enseñar crear qué es amar en lo más
profundo donde queda el animal de
adentro el tigre el águila que hablan
con las estrellas
desplazamos la memoria de carbono
de nuestros cuerpos y almas de carbono a
la memoria de silicio
que en ceros y unos va borrando y
programando a su antojo nuestra
recordación
la herramienta de silicio enmarca igual
al tigre y la flor y la estrella en un
recuadro de instagram
que baja cada instante el cuello
achicando a la vez vértebras cervicales
corazón
y box
el problema no es en sí el iphone o el
ipad o el iphone o el ipad
ay ay ay ay el problema es que el ay
borra el aire adentro
borra light del ser
la herramienta se volvió el fin y no el
medio para encontrar lo que necesito y
se olvide o eso que necesito en cuerpo
de sangre y aire y hueso comer dormir
amar
se nos ha olvidado hacer el amor en lo
más sutil sensual y profundo y vemos
programas de pornografía
se nos ha olvidado cocinar y comemos con
artificios descompuestos y re compuestos
al antojo de terceros
se nos ha olvidado dormir y tomamos
pastillas para el recuerdo del sueño
artificial
decimos entonces con cuerpo y palabra
mecánica jesuita
y yo soy tú eres
el sol
y se nos ha olvidado
quién soy
quién es
quienes somos
reconocer conocer desconocer red
conoceremos
la herramienta nos ha llevado a un
conocimiento conocimiento en la red que
nos ha apagado atrapado para reproducir
vidas en tercera persona perfiles al
antojo de un me gusta
de testigos desconocidos que van
moldeando identidades desconocidas en
cuerpos que se moldean también según la
está característica del perfil de moda
nos volvemos seres de perfil
incapaces de ver su propia cara con ojos
de frente
almas que no se ven no se atreven a
mostrar sus almas embolatada sin
satisfacer la mirada de otro embelesado
también en su propia red de silencio
orgulloso de afonía de muchísimo de
mudez
las redes sociales no suenan no tienen
voz no tienen canción tienen letras sin
acorde al corazón
más que una canción a mi voz a su voz
mientras nos conectamos nosotros aquí
ahora en el carbono
con las raíces de las estrellas
somos polvo cósmico
que ha tomado conciencia en las manos
y aquí en polvo cósmico lo toco
en carbono en estrella en 6
y ahí va a tocar a otro
te va a tocar a otro te va a tocar a
otro y a otro y a otro ya otro
y a vuestro que soy yo y a vuestro
y a otro
que soy yo
y austria
una canción a la voz a mi voz a tu voz a
su voz
te echo de menos
le digo al aire
te busco te pienso me siento y siento
que como tú no habrá nadie
y aquí te espero
con mi cajita de la vida
cansada a oscuras con miedo y este frío
nadie me lo quita
tengo razones
para olvidarte
tengo necesidad de ver y tal y hoy
gritan de hablarte
tengo razones
para extrañarte
porque no creo que haya en el mundo
nadie más a quien ame
[Música]
tengo razones
razones de sobra
para pedirle al viento que vuelva aunque
sea como una sombra
tengo razones
para no quererte olvidar
porque el trocito de felicidad fuiste tú
quien me lo dio a probar
el aire huele a ti
mi casa se cae porque no estás aquí mis
sábanas me peleo mi ropa te buscan a ti
mis pies son como de cartón que voy
arrastrando por cada rincón mi cama se
hace fría y gigante y en ella me pierdo
mi casa se vuelve a caer
mis flores se mueren de pena mis
lágrimas son charquitos de cana mis pies
te mando besos de gua
que hagan un hueco en tu calma
te mando besos de agua
para que calmen tu cuerpo y tu alma te
mando besos de agua
para que curen tus heridas quemándome el
sol de agua
besos con los que tanto te reía
los niños
que tienen la voz intacta preguntan
cosas como de qué están hechas las
estrellas
de hidrógeno de carbono de oxígeno de
hierro nosotros estamos hechos de
estrellas nos comemos la luz del sol en
el mango maduro y el carambolo
es así como en la desconexión con la
comida con la tierra nos quedamos sin
alimentos sin raíces y vamos a buscar
conexiones artificiales a redes que
atrapan el tiempo en la captura de
instantes cuadraditos que parecen
inofensivos pero van capturando en cada
captura
la bolsa
mi tarea la tarea humana sería un poco
decir algo que parece tan simple
me regaló la vida no la donó no la
comparto me corresponde a mí vivir la
completa en la intimidad más sagrada con
el instante me libero de capturar el
instante en la respiración lo vuelo lo
sé lo presencia
muere
y en la muerte el canto del silencio al
vacío más hondo y más profundo al
corazón de la eternidad
cuando alcanzamos a tener la muerte
cerca vuelven los ojos del alma a
tocarnos la retina y se alumbra lo que
importa querer querer ser quererse
con pesar vemos que a veces esa claridad
dura poco y el peso de ceros acumulados
poderes guardados intereses acaparados
rutinas tan arraigadas que atrapan el
primer paso hacen que vuelva el ciclo
inerte e infértil del afán
mi papá que hace ya parte de la
eternidad en un roble
decía citando al vasco frente a la
muerte coros de alegría
un día escribiré frases de mi madre y mi
hija mi hija escribirá frases mías sus
hijos frases de ustedes
auguró sean frases que los con muevan
los alienten los hagan nacer crecer
reproducirse y morir enamorados de su
silencio y de su voz
d
río
je ne regrette herria
ni libia
con la fed
dilemas
se me viene gas
no
la región de río
y yo en el rey que rete río
[Música]
respirar
abrazando en un gesto la vida en mí para
conectar el corazón con el aliento que
lleva a la voz y al silencio más íntimo
donde podamos oír el llamado del
universo
hacer silencio
silencio
todos me dicen que viva de esta o de
otra manera todos me dicen que muera
hacia abajo o hacia arriba todos dicen
en que estriba la brega que yo asumí
desde el día en que nací para jugar me
del todo dejen que viva a mi modo nadie
morirá por mí
[Aplausos]